hi there today we're looking at data
sets for data driven reinforcement
learning by Justin foo aviral Kumar
Bhave our knock'em George Tucker and
Sergey Lavine so this is a what you
would call a data set paper or a
benchmark paper and the main point or
the main area of the paper is was called
offline reinforcement learning so
offline reinforcement learning you
usually in reinforcement learning you
have this task right you have the agent
and you have the environment and the
agent gets some sort of observation and
it has to come up with an action in
response to that observation and then it
gets back a reward and another
observation and again has to come up
with an action and the goal is to
maximize the rewards over time that the
agent gets while interacting with the
environment so usually this is organized
in what are called episodes which
basically means if you have some sort of
environment right and here is the agent
and here is the goal well if the goal is
a inverted triangle and there are a
bunch of walls right here right so it's
it looks kind of a maze that the agent
has to navigate then one episode areas
could be the agent moving round until it
either finds the target or hits a wall
or it just kind of goes around and
around and then at some point you say
all right that's enough over game over
and usually in reinforcement learning
you perform many of these episodes and
then you learn from them so you perform
episodes and each episode gets into
usually some sort of replay buffer right
let's call this replay buffer and you do
this many times and at the same time
that you're doing this
you're using the things that you stored
here in order to learn write to the
agent learns from these things right so
it acts with the environment in this
loop in this fashion then once it has
done an episode it puts it into the reef
replay buffer and then it learns from
the actions it has performed this is
what is usually called online
reinforcement learning right so this
loop is online online means because the
agent learns from its own actions right
now in contrast to this there is offline
reinforcement learning so in offline
reinforcement learning the agent has to
learn from someone else's actions right
so this connection here is severed
instead you have other agents let's call
this agent one agent to multiple agents
agent three they all have their own
interaction with the environment right
environment environment interactions and
they feed their experience into they
perform these these episodes they feed
their experience into the replay buffer
and then the agent just has to learn
from that so whatever happened here this
was previous right and now the agent has
to learn how to maximize its reward just
from the experience that is in the
replay buffer from these other agents
this is what's called offline
reinforcement learning means the agent
learns from someone else's actions
usually the the power of reinforcement
learning of course comes from the fact
that you learn from your own actions it
means that for example if you already
have some successful trajectories here
right
you found the target you can try to
replicate
that because you know which actions you
performed and if you don't you know
change anything you're probably going to
find the target again just by randomness
alright because you've done it already
once and so on so you kinda know all the
intrinsics of your own algorithm that
led you to reach the target now this is
an entirely different case with all of
these other agents you have no clue how
they were acting why they were acting
right
you just know okay they did a series of
actions and that gave them some kind of
reward and you have no idea what their
reasoning was or anything all you really
can learn from is their sequence of
actions now why is that problematic
right so if all of the agents for
example if this is if this is a an
actual platform and is really right
steep here or this is all of here is
really steep cliffs right and you you
can actually fall off but the agents
they are they're humans right so they
don't want to fall off so what they're
gonna do is they're just gonna take
steps that are maybe like this or maybe
like this but they're they're humans
they're smart they're never they're
never gonna
they're never gonna fall off here right
why is this a problem if you're not
trying to learn from this experience and
your policy by some chance because you
might have some entropy in there or
something you you know what happens if
you make a move like this and you also
know what happens if you make a move
like this right already two humans have
done these moves but what happens if
you'd make a move like this you just
don't know right in classic
reinforcement learning you would get a
negative reward and you could learn from
that to not do this action anymore but
in in this case you simply don't have
any data to to to tell you what happens
when you go off there so you see that
there's a there's a problem if you are
not able to learn from your own
experience but you have to learn from
some thing
or someone else's experience the
distribution of experience that you have
available to you might be on like not
not fully specific of the of the
environment it might be very different
from what you would do and it might be
very not conducive to what you want to
do with it
so the task of offline reinforcement
learning is harder than online
reinforcement learning but it also has
many many applications sometimes it's
just not possible to do online
reinforcement learning when for example
in medical field right think of think of
the medical field where you want a robot
to perform a surgery you can't just do
reinforcement learning in with our
online techniques because they're just
gonna try a bunch of things and see what
works and you don't you don't like maybe
you want that I don't want that so
necessarily you're going to be left with
let's have this robot learn from human
experts right so that's a task for
offline reinforcement learning there are
many more tasks for example if you think
of search engine you will have many many
many logs from human searching things
and you just simply store them you
simply have them in a buffer now you
wanna maybe train a reinforcement
learning agent that I don't know serves
the best possible ads or something like
this you want to do this in a way that
you can use all of that data even though
that data wasn't collected by that
particular agent right there's the
crucial difference to supervised
learning again is that you have this
this interactive structure right this
multi-step interactive structure because
in a supervised learning you also have
you also have this buffer here right in
supervised learning you simply have your
labeled data set but the difference is
in supervised learning you always know
what the right action is currently right
because you
have the labels in offline reinforcement
learning you don't know you right you
might be here and there are three
actions available right and if you all
you know is that do the the demonstrator
a these actors here one of them has done
this and then this and then this and
then got a - you have you have no clue
what happens if you do this and then
this and then this right all you know is
that this action here might eventually
lead to a - right and you also can't try
it out because you can't try out this
path because you don't get a reward here
you have to find and this is the the
task here you'll have to find some other
example or stitch together they make a
good example here so this paper
basically proposes a benchmark for
offline RL algorithms so what they do is
they have a bunch of datasets right they
have a bunch of these replay buffers
around for different tasks they a
collection of this that they collected
with various techniques so there is
human demonstration there is other
agents and so on they have that and
you're supposed to take one of them
learn something learn an agent and then
evaluate it on an environment right and
they propose which ones are suitable for
this they give you the data and they
give you the environment to evaluate it
on in the end you'll get a score and you
can compare your offline RL algorithm
with others they also provide some
benchmark implementations for algorithms
that already do this and they show that
they don't really work well so one of
the one of the tasks is this maze here
in this maze you'll the the task is you
are somewhere let's say here and you
need to go
somewhere let's say here and you need to
find your way right and the
demonstrations you have the data in your
replay buffer or is such that this is
the same task but never the same start
and end points like you are tasked so
you might have one in your replay buffer
you might have one trajectory one
episode that went like this from one to
two right and you'll be able to see the
reward of that and you might have one
trajectory that was from two to three
like this right so both of these things
actually give you really high reward so
if you were an agent right and you had
to learn and now the task is please go
from one to three what you could do is
you could simply say ah I know I know
the green thing gave a pretty high
reward and the yellow thing grave a
pretty high reward I know the green
sting things started at one and I know
the yellow thing ended at three and I
know they both have this common location
so what I might do just is I might go to
that common location and then go on on
the different path right see you have to
somehow stitch together experience from
other agents in order to make your task
work now this is a very explicit example
of course what we want to do is we want
to do this in a more implicit deep
burning way ideally and not manually
stitch together other trajectories so
I'm pretty sure that would not that
would not be so so dumb right I'm pretty
sure there's a lot of data augmentation
you could do during training simply by
stitching together other other
trajectories right so from this
trajectory you could actually not only
could you make other gold conditioned
ways for example from here to here or
from here to here you could make from
here to here anywhere where you have
shared points you could go
um you could train a policy that goes
there and then goes further or something
like this I'm pretty sure there's
already an algorithm that does things
like this but I'm just thinking aloud
here
all right so this is one of the tasks
and you see that the the that that you
will have to learn a policy to go as
fast as possible from any point to any
other point and you're all you're given
is a database of experience that already
exists from some other agent but never
will probably never the exact route that
you need to learn right now all right so
the goal is how fast or how efficiently
can you do this this is one task in this
data set the next task is very similar
is this grid world here where there is
this red square a red triangle that's
your agent and then there is the green
square that's your goal or vice versa
and so you're basically tasked to not
hit the walls here and and to go about
your your way finding the target there
are more elaborate things like this mu
Joko environment here or the Aunt May's
where you have this little ant with you
know they're the spider legs so this is
no longer you can just move in an either
direction you have to actually control
the legs and there's also this arm this
robotic arm so you see there is a wide
diversity of tasks and also there is a
wide diversity of how the replay buffer
was constructed so in some cases the
replay buffer is actually constructed by
a human performing in this environment
so in this hand in this hand
manipulation tasks you'll have
demonstrations from humans you see it's
not particularly many samples here it's
a 5,000 samples which I guess are are is
a chopped-up version
of I'm not really sure how the human
things are constructed but you can
clearly guess that the degrees of
freedom that you have in a robotic hand
is much much higher than you could learn
just from these 5,000 samples if you
were to you know an online RL algorithm
that just does random exploration will
need much more than these 5,000 samples
and the 5,000 samples won't be iid
distributed with all the degrees of
freedom it will just be here's what a
human does right and so so you can think
of algorithms like inverse reinforcement
learning or something like this but here
in inverse reinforcement learning
usually you assume that the expert the
expert is kind of trying to achieve the
same reward as you do but this is not
necessarily the case here you have a
given reward structure but you are
tasked to simply learn from these
demonstrations you can see it's also
possible that there is this is
constructed by a policy and that usually
means that they so either it's um it's
constructed by let's say a reinforcement
learning algorithm that was trained in
an online fashion but maybe not as well
but also I think they have behavior
cloning policy that they got from human
demonstration I think so that there are
many ways also sometimes you have a
planner which is can you imagine it's
it's a it's an algorithm that wasn't
machine learned so I know almost
unthinkable but in these in these kind
of mazes you can actually do planning
algorithms that can can sort of so I
know this is crazy and crazy talk the
niche topic but there exist things like
a star search where where you can
construct the kind of shortest
path through these mazes and things like
this so yeah that's I know I know
that that is that's very niche but you
can construct policies like this and
then you can use those as your replay
buffer filling and you can already see
that this also will be a massively
different distribution of data then you
would get with an online RL algorithm
right so in conclusion they do test
other they do test other algorithms on
this in conclusion they say that most
offline our algorithms nowadays they
don't work well on these on these
datasets the only datasets where they do
work well is where the replay buffer was
generated by some sort of like here by
some sort of policy by some sort of
reinforcement learning policy so what
they would do is they would train an
online policy and the experience
generated by that online policy while it
learns will make up the replay buffer
and if you use that replay buffer for
offline learning then they say it tends
to work okay but if you have other
methods of collecting the data that are
very different from this offline sorry
from an from a reinforcement learning
collection approach then it tends not to
work as well all right so if you are
interested in offline RL please check
out this paper all their code is
available right here note that the link
in the paper doesn't seem to work the
true link is here I'll also put it in
the description and with that I wish you
good day bye